[Musique]
vendredi en radio et sur le web qui
chaque parcelle à kissama cas où elle a
fait signe aux lanières business cafep
la mecque mais qui sommes encore là mais
qui chambre mais nous avons une salle où
la presse marquant déjà nos palais royal
la prouesse de magalou belle gueule ou
patins au moulin au métro à six grands
invités officiels à l'abordage
invité à l'abordage là tu pense que
c'était une bonne idée d'inviter le
présume à candiac
ben oui parce que ce vendredi à
l'abordage officiellement le carnaval
il nous fallait une personnalité
[Musique]
rudy salles émission spéciale avec temps
bobo canal authentique jerrycans basse
et carnival all star à l'abordage ils ne
lâchent rien regretter à 15h sur
martinique la première